[Music]
this morning our special series school
matters looks at the return to school
and the unique challenges brought on by
the coronavirus
millions of students with special needs
usually require
a more intensive educational approach
experts worry they are being left behind
jamie wax visited a new york
organization that helps these children
overcome obstacles created by the
pandemic
on the south shore of new york's long
island a new approach is taking shape
he doesn't have much receptive language
and he was starting to understand
small things he was starting to want to
participate
in group activities which he never
really wanted to do
and then covet happened kristen teodoro
is mom to hudson an energetic
five-year-old on the autism spectrum
she's the founder of hudson's helping
hands
a non-profit she created earlier this
year during the early months of the
coronavirus pandemic
the group offers support to children
with special needs
by encouraging socialization and
engagement within a group setting
temperature checks are performed at the
entrance and all parents are required to
wear masks
at what point did you decide to do
something about this
a lot of the schools in my area
that were for special needs children
decided that they weren't opening
shortly after that i kind of just did a
post on my social media
and then when everybody volunteered i
was kind of like all right
i guess we're doing this the cdc
estimates one in
54 american children have autism
spectrum disorder
and one in six are diagnosed with a
developmental disability
let's face it it was a earthquake right
it was such a huge transition to take
special education and to move it home
christy patton is the vice dean of the
steinhardt school
of culture education and human
development at new york university
we have a misconception that a lot of
autistic individuals
don't want to be have friends don't want
to be in social situations
we know a lot of kids that they thrive
on those social situations
in addition to knowing that they thrive
on routine and having a schedule
really missing that that cohort whether
it's teachers and fellow students
someone that was bringing them out of
their shell exactly someone that
connected with them
more than 7 million public school
students receive special education
services in the united states
but a recent survey revealed that only
20 percent of those students received
the support they were entitled to
during the pandemic they're just having
fun and it's really
something special caitlin donahoe is the
mother of two
special needs children you can almost
feel like
you're missing out on your children's
childhood if that makes sense like
your kid might not be the star baseball
player or
you know on honor roll but when they're
here all together you can see
how each of them are special in their
own way have you seen other people
be inspired by the model you've set up
here we're our children's
biggest advocates and if you want
something done for your child you have
to do it yourself
you can't look at the school and say my
child's regressing do something about it
so i hope this inspires other parents to
kind of
you know take it into their own hands
for cbs this morning
jamie wax bridge hampton new york
well every every every day we we do a
story that brings a new issue in this
pandemic
center that had not considered before
and that's one of them and that's one of
them yeah and there
and and as as she points out as parents
you have to be advocates for your kids
and you have to put them first
the teachers are doing so much and
adjusting enormously in this and trying
to do everything but
but everybody's got to do more yeah i
think a lot of times people forget that
teachers have kids too
yes and so they're trying to teach your
kids they're trying to work with their
kids they're trying to raise
their own families at the same time it's
a lot it's a lot it is a lot and some
have actually resigned because there's
been too much during that pandemic
which is another tragedy on top of all
of it